Two medium Americanos.
Coming right up. How's it going brother?
Did you read it yet?
What? Dude, how are you so fast?
Aw, did you guys have your first kiss yet?
No, I'm waiting.
Take her out of here.
Kevin, you're a good man.
This neighborhood is concerned
about the killing of a 17 year old.
Do they have any idea who did it?
Whatever gang he's in and then they'll just hide him.
Why is everyone saying it's a gang thing?
Police are still looking for leads in the case of slain Kennedy High School student, Kevin Broadus.
Our emotions are raw.
Everybody in this room is hurting.
Kevin Broadus was not in the gang.
We appreciate your time.
Will you please send the next person in?
My friend just got killed.
You can't expect me just to sit
around and not do anything about it.
The police have already made up their minds.
They're gonna write this whole
thing off as a gang killing.
Someone needs to do something.
Why are you so interested?
It just doesn't really make any
sense why anyone will kill Kevin?
I don't know why, but maybe we're just
gonna have to learn to live with that.
You stop this nonsense.
This is a murder investigation.
You don't know what could happen.
Addison, he's mixed up with some heavy people.
They're dangerous.
You said you got something for me.
Do you see where we are right now?
My wife had to find this. Are you a dealer?
No!
Were you supplying my son?
No! Absolutely not!
I'm worried about you.
If you came here trying to talk me out
of doing anything crazy, don't bother.
I can't be a part of this anymore.
Now I got nothing to lose.
Addison, don't be stupid. Do not go there!